well tonight a warning to parents some
las vegas supermarket companies are
being sued for allegedly selling tainted
baby food
it's a case against baby food
manufacturers as well as distributors
kirsten joyce now has the details
that lawsuit filed today by law firms
eglit adams and kemp jones is on behalf
of six families and seven
children it claims baby food containing
high levels of arsenic lead and mercury
worsened existing autism conditions in
children
you know it's a sad thing when people
have autism it's
it's it's worse than we have a food
product like this that contains toxic
substance
that has made the problem worse for
these families and that's the relief we
see
attorneys are suing food makers
including gerbers beechnut best organic
and happy baby for making the baby food
mariana's supermarkets and la bonita
supermarkets are also named in the case
the attorneys say under nevada law the
grocery stores are liable for selling
the alleged toxic product
one father describes the changes in his
child's behavior he says
came after feeding him the baby food
he was slower to understand
when i would give him commands or talk
to him the ability to understand to
reason to respond
it definitely diminished and uh
i guess it's focused in addition to that
and even sometimes frustration level and
aggressiveness
also increase most of the children are
older now they were given this food in
question when they were babies now the
attorneys say this is the result of an
extensive study presented to congress
two years ago
they expect this case to be a lengthy
one when they return to court sometime
this summer
we did reach out to our local
supermarkets but have not heard back